[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live on attend vos
points de vue vos commentaires et vos
questions pour alimenter notre édition
du jour ce matin lors d'une conférence
de presse le premier ministre a pris la
parole pour donner le détail des
annonces des manuels macron jean castex
a montré qu'il était pour le moins pied
sur le frein sur ceux des confinement en
trois temps affirmant d'ailleurs qu'il
est trop tôt pour parler de
déconfinement on écoute tout de suite
la situation s'améliore grâce aux
efforts de tous mais ces chiffres pour
encourageants qu'ils soient reste encore
fragile
nous ne pouvons donc pas baisser la
garde
il est donc prématuré de parler de
déconfinement il est surtout
indispensable de ne pas baisser la garde
et nous ne pourrons franchir chacune de
ces étapes que si la situation
épidémique nous le permet si l'évolution
favorable que nous observons se poursuit
si la pression sur nos services
hospitaliers
les commerces ouvriront ce samedi les
bars et les restaurants resteront fermés
jusqu'au 20 janvier
êtes vous favorable à la réouverture des
bars et des restaurants avant le 20
janvier c'est la question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter c'est la question du
jour
vous y répondez dès maintenant et vous
pouvez évidemment je vous y encourage
participer à cette émission en nous
postant vos commentaires et vos
questions et nos invités se feront un
plaisir de vous répondre
d'ailleurs à propos d' invités nous
avons en plateau avec nous aujourd'hui
en direct sylvain courage bonjour vous
êtes rédacteur en chef à l'obs merci
d'être ici et face à vous vincent
trémolet red-act directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du figaro merci encore d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui
jean castex je le disais à détailler les
annonces du président de la république
ce matin d'abord l'un et l'autre qu'avez
vous pensé de cette intervention du
premier ministre
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué
particulièrement sylvain courage
effectivement il a essayé de freiner un
petit peu c'est une question de dosage
ce ce cette sortie en sifflet du
confinement le président de la
république avait donné des perspectives
bon les trois étapes semble s enchaîné
naturellement donc évidemment l'espoir
avait repris dans la population et donc
castex d attention rien est acquis alors
est ce que c'est c'est certainement de
répartition des rôles
je sais pas si elle est écrite d'avant
centre le gentil et le méchant
en tout cas les gentils plus tôt enfin
disons que emmanuel macron il me semble
à prononcer le mot de déconfinement dans
son dans son allocution est donc le
premier ministre nous dit attendez c'est
pas du déconfinement donc effectivement
alors ça va ça va encore être sans doute
commenté comme une hésitation des
injonctions contradictoires de
l'exécutif
en vérité c'est un peu logique puisque
voilà il faut doser encore une fois la
réponse et ne pas précipiter les choses
parce qu'évidemment si une troisième
vague intervenait on se tournerait vers
le même exécutif pour le lui reprocher
vincent trémolet qu'est ce qui vous a
marqué particulièrement dans cette
intervention de jean castex matin alors
moi je reconnais comme sylvain que c'est
très compliqué
de mener cet exercice puisque les gens
veulent à la fois être protégés et est
libéré
donc c'est contradictoire que c'est une
espèce de jeu de mikado vous savez où si
vous prenez un des uns des morceaux de
bois tout peut s'effondrer
ensuite je vois quand même un défaut de
forme qui vaut en castex va devenir
problématique c'est à dire que les
conférences de presse se suivent et se
ressemblent et le ton est le même et la
rhétorique est la même et l'atmosphère
est la même et je crois que edouard
philippe était parvenu pendant le
premier confinement à partager les
inquiétudes des français quand elle
était importante et à faire partager
presque physiquement et dans son
éloquence leurs espérances et que donc
il correspondait au moment et là vous le
trouvez trop neutre je le trouve trop
comment dire robotique non pas robotique
mais presque enfermé dans son souci de
ne pas rater ce deuxième déconfinement
sans montrer l'agilité la souplesse une
forme peut-être même de décontraction
vis-à-vis de l'événement qui donnerait à
son propos plus de force
vous trouvez qu'on manque même
d'émotions en tout cas je vais il me
semble qu'il a on en parlera tout à
l'heure pour les cultes mais c'est
pareil pour pour d'autres domaines il me
semble que il était arrivé parce qu'on
considérait enfin emmanuel macron
considéré qu' edouard philippe était
trop technocratique et accompagna était
accompagné d'une morgue que les français
ne voulaient plus voir et jean castex
devait être quelqu'un qui était à la
fois authentique proche des gens et et
employant leur langue
hélas ce à quoi on assiste c'est quand
même un exercice administratif c'est à
dire qu'on a l'impression d'avoir un
super préfet devant nous et on sait que
cela induit sur sur les français qui
regardent cette intervention
systématique bas je pense qu'il n'a pas
l'autorité qu'avait son prédécesseur
pour ces moments là et que ça s'exprime
déjà dans les sondages
c'est très compliqué parce qu'il a vécu
une période très compliquée mais qui
l'est déjà il ya déjà une usure
qui se fait jour auprès de jean castex
auprès j'allais dire auprès d'olivier
ferrand et de jérôme salomon c'est à
dire que les les interventions se sont
multipliés il y en a eu énormément il se
trouve que l'on connaît les choses avant
donc l'effet est quand même déjà un peu
émoussé avant même qu'il prenne la
parole est donc ce rendez vous
à mon avis est en train d'apparaître
pour beaucoup de téléspectateurs comme
un rendez-vous qui n'est pas agréable et
qui n'est pas extraordinairement
finalement éclairant puisqu'un certain
nombre de choses avaient déjà été
données avant même qu'il parle sylvain
courage aimerait qu'on réagisse et à ce
que vient sur la forme c'est déjà une
imposition de style on s'aperçoit que la
situation de leader philippe était tout
aussi inconfortable mais il avait réussi
par une sorte d'ironie qui lui naturel à
dire une chose tout en laissant
entrevoir autre chose bref il avait créé
une complicité
en fait avec les français dans un moment
terriblement
anxiogène et bazancourt et bien le voilà
je pense c'est ça qui n'ont qu'à castex
et cette souplesse rhétorique cette
agilité presque deux comédiens pour
faire passer les messages et donc
effectivement la communication est un
peu raide un peu et prendre parfois même
un peu autoritaire et c'est ça qui
passent pas parce que on sait que sa une
les danses diverses graves comme celle
dans laquelle on est les français sont
sensibles à cette forme que donne jean
castex à ces interventions bien sûr
parce qu'on la grille mais on leur
demande des efforts et donc encore
faut-il savoir le demander sans
indisposer sans être sentencieux sans
être trop autoritaire donc c'est
vraiment une question de style presque
widnes de rapport au langage à la
posture et et castex ne passe pas ça
c'est vrai qu'il est peut-être de 2
enfin comme vous comment dire de
tempérament c'est à dire que je pense
que chez edouard philippe ce qui a fait
sa popularité à ce moment là parce que
c'est à ce moment là qu'il explose si
vous parliez à tout le monde dans tout
le spectre politique
les gens vous disais il était à la
hauteur il a fait le boulot
et quand il parlait il donnait
l'impression de mener une charge plus
grande que lui qui ne lui apporterait
rien mais qu'il devait mener parce qu'il
était là à cet endroit là du navire jean
castex montre que la charge est lourde
mais en gros qui la domine est que ceux
qui ne l'appliquent pas font que ça
marche pas et donc il ya une espèce de
de ton qui a l'air de dire un peu de
proviseur qui a l'air de dire aux élèves
vous n'avez pas été à la hauteur il ya
eu cette formule extraordinairement
maladroite
quand on a commencé à parler de
déconfinement il a dit il faut pas
desserré la bride ou les français ce
sont des ce que je suis un âne est ce
que j'ai un mulet à ce que c'est un
cheval bon et et et il me semble que la
différence entre les deux c'est ça et le
verbe dans ces moments là ça compte ça
compte énormément
voilà et c'est cette anarchie et fait
partie de l'art politique et on
s'aperçoit quand même que c'est sûrement
un haut fonctionnaire extrêmement
performant mais que sur le plan
politique il n'a pas acquis un certain
nombre d'éléments qui lui permettent
d'emporter l'adhésion
alors du coup pour revenir ma question
de départ est ce qu'il ferait
rô le des confinement est ce que
devaient tu es dans sa rigidité
il leva même sur la question du
consentement
elle repose sur la compréhension les
gens se disent pourquoi on interdit
pourquoi on autorise et là je crois que
la grande difficulté devant laquelle
ceux qui sont contraints ou ceux dont
les activités sont interdites se pose
c'est que dans leur esprit se disent est
ce que cette précaution et sanitaires
dans ces cas-là il accepte
est ce que ces précautions et politique
dans ce cas là il accepte moins est ce
que cette précaution est judiciaire
c'est à dire un risque pénal pour le
premier ministre et les ministres et là
ils l'acceptent plus du tout en disant
c'est nous qui au faîte subissons le
fait que ces hommes politiques ne
veulent pas prendre le risque et je
pense que cette interrogation est dans
les esprits des restaurateurs des
bistrotiers des patrons de stations de
ski du monde de la culture et et créer
un très grand scepticisme si ce n'est
une défiance
parce qu'on sent très bien que que il
yal dans le discours quelque chose qui
correspond à l'image que l'on a du
fonctionnaire qui ouvre le parapluie
tout à l'heure jean castex expliqué j'ai
dit qu'il fallait faire mais des boîtes
de nuit au mois de juillet au mois
d'août tout le monde s'est moqué de moi
et on avait l'impression qu'ils
déroulent et la justesse et la comment
dire la l'efficience de ses décisions
comme s'ils devaient plaider ce qu'il
devait j'ai bien fait vous avez eu tort
et j'ai eu raison
et donc voilà moi je pense que dans
l'esprit de ceux qui croient qu'il
freine trop se mêlent maintenant un peu
de soupçon sur est ce qu'il freine parce
que ces sanitaires ou est ce qui freine
parce que c'est bureaucratiques ou
administratif du coup derrière tout ça
sylvain courage par rapport à ce que dit
vincent très mauvaise que l'on peut
trouver dans sa communication à côté
infantilisant
pour les françaises oui certainement
puisque on a parlé de sa posture un peu
d'autorité
voilà je m'écoutais je vais serrer la
bride enfin il ya ce rapport qui est pas
trés qui est pas très confiant avec avec
la communauté nationale et donc
évidemment les français peuvent avoir
l'impression que qu'on les prend pour
des pour des benêts ça c'est certain
c'était le risque en raison de la
défiance aussi ou pour des enfants c'est
à dire des gens qui ne sont pas
suffisamment intelligents et selah sue
et sa posture technocratique en surplomb
revient pas suffisamment intelligent
pour maîtriser les tenants et les
aboutissants de ces décisions donc
encore une fois c'est vraiment un
problème de communication et quand on
veut séparer la communication de la
politique on fait une erreur parce que
là c'est ça qu'est ce qui reste l'a26 si
on devait tirer de de file de
l'intervention
pour la première il ya la question des
30 personnes dans les églises qui va
poser et la deuxième c'est cette phrase
sur les stations de ski qui sont
ouvertes avec les remontées mécaniques
qui sont fermés qui renvoie à cette
notion inventée par le génie de la
formule française fans dont je crois que
ça vient d'allemagne d'ailleurs de
l'absurde distants c'est à dire que la
la on a beaucoup entendu voilà l'idée
que sylvain disais tout à l'heure
les français sont assez intelligents
pour comprendre en tout cas ils sont
assez intelligents pour voir qu'un
certain nombre de décisions
rien que dans leur énoncé apparaissent
comme des messages du graphique donc si
vous voulez les gorilles on va le
rappeler c'est un site parodique voilà
on n'est pas le figaro mais parfois
c'est aussi utile que cigales et et si
vous voulez 7
cette idée de stations de ski qui sont
ou plutôt que de dire oh boy a pas de
saison les stations de ski seront
ouvertes mais les remontées mécaniques
seront fermés renvoie aux biens
essentiels et non essentiels ou dans les
supermarchés des choses étaient ouverts
tout était fermé on pouvait juste et de
la layette de deux mois de deux ans mais
pas un pantalon de 4 ans beau fond et ça
il devait en sortir emmanuel macron a
quand même dénoncé la bureaucratie dans
son intervention et il n'en est pas
sorti il ya encore eu aujourd'hui dans
le le discours de jean castex quelque
chose qui prête le flanc à la critique
de la dérive bureaucratique française
important sylvain courage cette
infantilisation on est aussi un petit
peu responsable nous français c'est nous
qui sommes aussi ce n'est pas les
sachants le rapport pour les pas par
exemple pour les fêtes de noël on a tous
envie de savoir
jusqu'à combien de convives on pourra se
réunir pour faire pour fêter ensemble et
en famille donc on est aussi en demande
de c'est bien sûr de ce cadre on va dire
pour pouvoir avancer continue à vivre
rouvrir les vannes un peu d'une vie
normale
bien sûr il ya une demande de protection
et de et voilà et de presque d'être
guidé dans cette période donc les
effectivement la relation est complexe
parce que on sait que les français sont
toujours en attente d'une solution qui
vient du pouvoir central de l'état et
donc le cas ce texte n'est pas où tous
ceux qui qui agissent comme lui
elles ne sont pas là par hasard c'est
aussi tout un tout une culture politique
qui remonte à loin et donc effectivement
ils attendent des consignes et en même
temps il adore se moquer des consignes
pointe et l'arbitraire l'absurdité c'est
aussi aussi ancien que le rapport des
français au pouvoir tutélaire et donc on
est bien dans ce dans ce système et
c'est vrai qu'à la fin le risque
politique pour le gouvernement c'est de
perdre beaucoup de 2,6 de son autorité
de sa crédibilité
et voilà alors il ya un petit bémol à
faire peut-être de là si on se place du
point de vue des manuels macron c'est
que l'on est en reprenant le parallèle
avec edouard philippe
c'est que edouard philippe avait pris la
lumière avait trouvé le ton est donc
emmanuel macron lui
par comparaison avait avait souffert je
dirais que peut-être que la
communication un peu caricatural voire
grotesque de castex protège macron parce
qu'elle réévalue sa parole donc dans le
système disons de l'exécutif
castex et un est un paratonnerre voilà
puisque finalement apparemment emmanuel
macron souffre au moins en terme d'image
donc il ya aussi la stratégie politique
peut-être derrière à analyser moi je
crois que vous avez raison sur la la
dépendance des français à l'état et le
fait qu'ils sont contradictoires et une
phrase d'alain peyrefitte qui dit le
couple en france le couple entre les
tailles des l'individu est un couple
maudit et c'est vrai ça marche jamais
mais ils sont toujours ensemble
mais je pense quand même que l'eia de
france il y en a une qui est habitué à
siffler l'état comme un domestique qui
n'est pas contente quand layton le
materne le pattern pas pour reprendre la
formule de sylvain tesson
mais il ya quand même une france plus
libérale ou plus qui aimerait que l'état
la laisse faire et il se trouve que
cette france là une partie de cette
france là c'est celle qui ne peut pas
ouvrir ssl dans à 3 09 millions d'ivoire
vous aider avec des subventions et dons
qu'ils sont ils se sentent 2 x 2 2 x
puni en fait et parce que n'ont pas le
même rapport d'exigence à l'état ils
n'attendent pas tout de lui il ya une
phrase très frappante de macron
c'était lundi ou mardi mardi quand ils
disent nous avons montré en neuf mois
que l'état pouvait être efficace plus
efficace et je pense que pour beaucoup
de gens tout ce qui a marché s'était
malgré l'état et le grand malentendu il
est là et dans les enquêtes d'opinion
d'ailleurs quand on voit ce qu'ils
approuvent le confinement ce qu'il
faisait a besoin on trouve à peu près de
55 % approuvent 45 sont contre et je
pense ça correspond assez de psychologie
de qui existe dans notre pays depuis
traîner ce alors c'est cette france des
entrepreneurs de cette france qui se
lève tôt c'est d'autant plus paradoxal
pour emmanuel macron de c'était la
sienne que c'était censément la sienne
oui oui oui
êtes vous favorable à la réouverture des
restaurants et des bars avant le 20
janvier c'était la question du jour on
vous la poser sur twitter et vous êtes
donc 60 de tous pour cent si je me
trompe pas à vous à répondre que vous
êtes favorable à cette réouverture avant
le 20 janvier allez on passe à la suite
jean castex maintien la jauge à 30
personnes dans les lieux de culte au
moins jusqu'au 15 décembre
on écoute un effet les lieux de culte
ont été en france comme ailleurs des
lieux de contamination et la circulation
virale demeure encore forte dans notre
pays ces lieux accueilleront d'abord 30
personnes dans le respect des règles
sanitaires
puis cette jauge évoluera
progressivement en fonction de la
situation sanitaire et de l'échéance du
15 décembre
comme d'autres établissements recevant
du public
il pourra s'agir d'une georges en
fonction de la capacité globale
d'accueil du lieu les discussions se
poursuivent avec les autorités
religieuses
pouvez-vous que le maintien de la limite
de 30 personnes par église est une
humiliation c'est la question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter en ce moment vous
continuez à commenter ce sujet de
l'émission à poser vos questions à vous
invite à nos invités ils vont vous
répondre avec plaisir dans cette
deuxième partie en tout cas pour
reprendre cette intervention de jean
castex la réaction
l'épiscopat ne s'est pas fait attendre
ils dénoncent le maintien de cette jauge
et parle de graves erreurs l'église
attendait c'est vrai une rectification
de cette mesure après l'appel du
président de la république à l'issue de
son discours du 24 novembre le maintien
de la jauge à 30 personnes et plutôt une
surprise
quel est votre sentiment sylvain courage
vous comprenez que cette se maintient
d'un jour je sois jugé irréaliste pour
reprendre les termes de l'épiscopat et
inapplicable par certains responsables
de l'église
ben oui parce que c'est comme si on
ouvrait un tout petit peu la porte alors
que les églises sont sont vastes et
surtout les églises ne se considèrent
pas comme des boutiques
enfin le clergé ne considère pas que les
lieux de culte soit des boutiques pour
eux évidemment le la messe est un
sacrement et donc la réunion des fidèles
c'est au coeur de leurs de leurs
pratiques et donc c'est pour ça qu'elle
a mon avis la réaction est d'autant plus
vive que voilà ils sont traités avec 7 à
la 7 cette jauge administrative
alors qu'il parle de sacré vous avez
trouvé votre centre et mollet vous avez
qualifié en tout cas sur twitter cette
jauge de 30 personnes de vexations
public
oui parce que c'est ce que j'avais écrit
dans l'édito après la déclaration de
macron et ce qui est très curieux c'est
que emmanuel macron après son sa
déclaration comme tels que le relate le
figaro notamment avaient appelé mons
aignan debout la moe fort donc le patron
des évêques de france pour lui a coûté
ya eu un malentendu seront évidemment on
va essayer d'adapter les choses à voir
une jauge plus réalistes et bien entendu
entre une église de campagne ou à 30 on
est peut-être trop une chapelle de
campagne et nice et saint sulpice vous à
30 on n'arrive même pas à se retrouver à
savoir que tellement c'est grand et on
peut peut-être trouver un juste
équilibre et faire faire en fonction du
lieu ce qui apparaît comme comme un du
bon sens va tout simplement comme du bon
sens
là où il ya quelque chose de vexatoires
il me semble c'est d'abord dans la
légèreté avec laquelle le monseigneur
castex monseigneur tout cela jean castex
à l'évacuer à évacuer la question comme
si c'était un problème comme le décidera
uniquement administratif alors qu'il ya
un arrière-plan dans cette histoire ça
commence avec le discours de nice il
fait un discours très beau pour rendre
hommage aux victimes de l'attentât de
nice dans lequel il dit la liberté
d'exercer son culte publiquement est une
liberté fondamentale la république ne
transige pas avec cette liberté ne
transigera pas c'est un message qu'il
envoie directement aux catholiques
en dix ans elle ne transigera pas là
dessus on est on est le jour du
confinement
là dessus il l'a interdit le culte
public se crée une petite tension les
catholiques vont les évêques vont devant
le conseil d'état le conseil d'état dit
ça va pas las le protocole demandés par
l'état il faut vous voyez vite parce que
ça peut pas tenir bon là-dessus la
déclaration macron a grandi on va
s'arranger
ça va s'améliorer et puis paf revient
une déclaration qui est à l' inverse de
tout ce qu'ils avaient entendu en privé
les représentants de l'épiscopat on a
même parlé d'une erreur pour possible
que au lieu de dire 30 personnes il
aurait dû dire 30% évidemment cela il
ajoute en plus un élément qui n'a pas
été invoqués devant le conseil d'état et
qui est c'est la première fois qu'on
l'entend qui est ce sont des foyers de
contamination aura quoi fait-il
référence fait référence à la réunion
évangélique
oui ce vers quoi il devrait lui john
catoe lilou et du mois de février à
mulhouse réunion dont on a vu des images
où les gens ne portait pas de masque où
c'était une réunion avec beaucoup de
sensibilité donc les gens se tenait par
le bras enfin bon il y avait un certain
nombre de gestes qui ne sont pas du tout
les gestes à appliquer dans les églises
et et je crois que depuis le mois de mai
la reprise des cultes il n'y a jamais eu
un foyer de contamination établis dans
ces lieux là donc il a ajouté au fait de
ne pas à la fin de non recevoir
une phrase un peu à l'emporte-pièce qui
a été considéré par beaucoup comme une
espèce de vexations supplémentaire donc
là ça crée une tension qui a modelé
parfaitement inutile je crois que
je puis dire que cette jauge de 30 n'est
pas tenable et que donc les gens vont se
rendre dimanche dans leur église vous
faire comme en valais compte et
interroger effectivement ça leur revient
c'est elle c'est l'évêché des yvelines
qui s'interrogeait un peu en faisant la
démonstration par l'absurde va-t-on
devoir faire plusieurs offices pour
accueillir le public extra il est vrai
que dans les magasins on applique une
ratio de nombre de de visiteurs par
mètre carré on pourrait estimer que les
églises répond aux mêmes et je crois
qu'on parce qu'on va peut-être élargir
le trou puisque je crois que les
français catholiques pratiquants
observant qu on en dise et 2% de la
population
donc c'est pas non plus un être qui
captive le 98 % le reste du pays ça les
intéresse peut-être mais c'est pas pour
eux il n'y a pas de sujet au fait mais
je pense quand même qu'il faut regarder
ça aussi dans le cadre d'un certain
nombre de libertés suspendue du fait des
nécessités sanitaire mais qui se
multiplient quand même et qui devrait au
moins je ne sais pas si c'est préoccupé
mais intéressé tout démocrate qui
devrait regarder ça en se disant on va
rester vigilant là dessus parce que la
liberté d'exercer son culte comme la
liberté d'expression comme la liberté de
prendre des photos dans une
manifestation comme la liberté de
circuler font partie des libertés
fondamentales et je me disais tout à
l'heure il a été question d'une erreur
qui aurait commise le président qu'il
aurait pu corriger en fait a priori ce
n'est pas une erreur puisque le chiffre
de 30 est donc confirmée comment il faut
interpréter ce maintien de cette jauge
de 30 personnes est-ce que la motivation
de cette décision elle est plus
politique que sanitaire je sais pas elle
est absurde dans le sens où celle
forexi-sa y avoir une sensibilité
politique
yale il peut être une sensibilité
politique je pense que politiquement
c'est comme un peu idiot pas ça mais à
quelqu'un qui est qui qui qui est connu
pour ce son nom sa pratique religieuse
non mais que tactiquement emmanuel
macron veut mordre à droite oui par
contre il est là le le l'électorat
catholique élargi ça n'est pas décisif
mais ça n'est pas rien surtout quand on
veut être élu à droite
donc je vois pas l'intérêt de
ce matin il y avait les radios
classiques avec l'évêque de nanterre
quelqu'un de très pondéré enseignants
aux vieux qui disait qu en jeu quand je
vois ces revirements j'ai l'impression
de revivre l'école libre je vois pas
l'intérêt pour emmanuel macron
d'entendre sa fin politique je ne le
vois pas après peut-être il ya quelque
chose de pas ce qu'ils s'arrogent ça
ressemble aux stations ski ça ressemble
à beaucoup de choses
une espèce de comment dire d'étroitesse
administrative qui fait qu on se bute
sur quelque chose on dit c'est ça que
j'ai décidé et peut-être on croyait
qu'il y avait du jean pierre raffarin
chez jean castex peut-être qu'il ya du
alain juppé ça c'est une autre
possibilité le président aurait pu
corriger t-il sans doute pourquoi
pourquoi il n'a pas donné satisfaction
là son premier ministre est en première
ligne et a confirmé les chiffres
donc c'est toujours délicat pour le
président de le déjuger mais je suis
d'accord que pour mac rond il ya un
enjeu politique en dehors de sa
sensibilité personnelle même puisqu'on
sait que quelqu'un attentif à la
question de la religion catholique
donc je pense qu'il va tenter une
médiation forcément mais il est obligé
d'attendre un peu puisque la
communication n'a été très net sur ce
point et beaucoup de choses contre bacon
grise mais c'est cette chose-là a été
affirmée fortement donc les c'est
toujours plus difficile de faire demi
tour ou de sortir par le haut de mai
c'est peut-être aussi un premier élément
qui va nous rappeler ce qu'on a vécu
entre emmanuel macron edouard philippe à
la fin du premier confinement ou un
certain nombre de tensions sont apparues
entre les manuels macron qui avait une
volonté d'ouvrir plus vite et edouard
philippe qui disait n'en restons
prudents et dans le remplacement
d'edouard philippe par jean castex il y
avait l'idée il est trop raide on va le
prendre quelqu'un jean castex et les
messieurs déconfits demande voilà c'est
celui qui va ouvrir grand les portes bon
là et on a un peu l'impression de
revivre le début d'une histoire que l'on
a déjà connu alors je vous fais part
aussi des réactions des internautes sur
ce sujet sur le figaro.fr l'internaute
muchi muchi ne comprend pas le
couvre-feu du 25 décembre effectivement
je crois pas qu'ils aient de cunha de il
ne sera pas le 25 décembre il ne sera
pas le 31 on peut passer la nuit
jusqu'au petit matin avec avec sa
famille ou ses amis chris kraus
l'audition au figaro.fr nous catholiques
feront une grande messe le 25 décembre
et lan sur lefigaro.fr propose de fermer
les frontières mais d'ouvrir les messes
contrôle de réflexion nicole 0,6 sur
lefigaro.fr demande si les limitations
seraient seront également en place dans
les mosquées est ce que les mosquées
aussi devront limiter le nombre de vols
à la 30 tous les tous les lieux de culte
sont concernés par cette disposition
à propos de la mesure sanitaire qui est
invoquée pour pour limiter ce nombre à
est ce que est ce qu'on peut imaginer
que dans la tête de des bagnoles mâcon
de jean castex et il s'imagine que les
catholiques ne sont pas assez
responsables pour pour appliquer les
règles de sanitaire qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière tout ça moi je pense qu'il ya
une très grande culture sur les cultes
je pense quand même que la clé c'est ça
c'est à dire que le culte catholique
n'est pas la même chose que le culte
protestant qui n'est pas la même chose
que le plus aux musulmans qui valait me
trouve que le culte juif et en attendant
la ligier de religion catholique la
réunion communautaire n'est pas
simplement une réunion commune au talent
se fait autour d'un sacrement et donc
les gens doivent être là et ils ne
peuvent pas il faut une pression ils
disent qu'ils aient une présence réelle
de dieu et leur présence doit doit être
aussi réelle n'est pas virtuel donc la
vision marche pas très bien bon et à
partir de là je crois que ça sera pas
été pris en compte pour pouvoir pour les
gens qui je suis non mais qui veulent
être bien au fait quand vous dites la
présence visio visio dessus du but ça
veut dire que les messes diffusé en
radio ou sur la télévision ne suffisent
pas menant aux fidèles ils ont besoin
d'être en tout cas elles ne sont pas
mignons et ensuite
dans un mail parce que c'était quoi
votre question c'était c'était est ce
que les catholiques se sont remis en
question sur leur capacité à faire
preuve de responsabilité dans
l'abomination des mesures sanitaires
on met en doute finalement ils ont ils
ont proposé des des protocoles
oui mais c'est vous le leur a demandé
d'ailleurs là il me semble que c'est une
méconnaissance du sujet et une le fait
que les catholiques du fait de ce qu'ils
sont comme je disais dans le pourcentage
aux populations doivent être considérées
par beaucoup comme insignifiant
politiquement et socialement sont à peu
près au rang des libraires quoi donc
comme on les aime bien mais c'est fort
ce que vous dit c'est pas très important
un peu excessif
je sais pas c'est une supposition et à
partir de là c'est pas le sujet central
est donc le sujet est traité jean castex
dans sa déclaration dit par exemple nous
allons à partir du 28 novembre les lieux
de pulls pourront réouvrir mais ils sont
déjà ouverts donc ça montre à quel point
je peux être c'est moins concentrés sur
ce sujet que sur le télétravail que sur
le lait les commerçants que sur les
restaurants et donc c'est aborder avec
légèreté et c'est pour ça que ceux qui
subissent l'interdiction ont
l'impression d'une vexations certains
disent d'une humiliation
parce que ce qui est pour eux me
centrales est essentielle apparaît comme
complètement secondaire voire
inintéressant pour ceux qui décident
sylvain courage vous pensé que les
catholiques en france sont pris un peu
par dessus la jambe et et ne compte pas
vraiment aux yeux du gouvernement
ils ont perdu de l'influencé politique
c'est certain ça ccc history la date de
fadhma kron non et je pense que après
tout dépend vraiment de la sensible de
la sensibilité des dirigeants
et presque de leurs convictions
personnelles dans le cas de jean castex
je répète que n'a pas de conviction
personnelle sur ce sujet et que ça
explique peut-être le traitement un peu
léger ou l'ignorance
voilà le mépris éventuellement qu'il a
pu avoir pour ce sujet et on est donc
probablement emmanuel macron qui lui ad
a des convictions personnelles sur le
sujet et un intérêt politique majeur
effectivement à essayer de contenter un
certain électorat de droite mais il ya
urgence à corriger le tir je pense et on
verra ça dans les jours qui viennent
c'est une intrigue très intéressant
d'ailleurs pour pour à la fois
comprendre la stratégie de macron et
peut-être l'écart qui se creuse avec
jean cassel et puis ça nous rappelle
gagne c'est très intéressant la
sociologie du catholicisme parce que
comme je le disais c'est devenu
extrêmement minoritaires pour ceux qui
sont observés mais ça reste quand même
une population qui a des relais qui qui
qui a qui fait partie d'un certain
nombre de secteurs de métiers etc
donc il peut se faire entendre et puis
qu'il ya un héritage c'est permanent qui
dit liste dans la de l'histoire de
france il ya une longue phrase
chrétienne tout le monde n'y crois pas
mais beaucoup ne veut pas que cette
phrase disparaissent et donc ce sont des
gens qui ne sont pas observant qu'ils ne
vont pas la messe mais qui quand il peut
y avoir des épisodes comme ça on une
sympathie ou se disent mais pourquoi on
les empêche pourquoi on les vexe
inutilement donc là on voit revivre
cette sociologie un peu un peu
insaisissable que fourquet a analysé
clic est très intéressante et
l'internaute
li hao belle sur lefigaro.fr ne nous
démentira pas puisqu'il dit les
croyances de telle ou telle religion non
pas à interférer avec la gestion
sanitaire et inversement les
réalisations ce sera ma dernière
question est-ce que selon vous il faut
une jauge proportionnel à la taille des
équipages ça peut paraître la mesure qui
serait à la fois rationnelle du point de
vue de la politique sanitaire comme
comme le souligne votre votre auditeurs
et qui permettrait effectivement
d'adapter la taille de legend of zelda
le nombre de fidèles à la taille de
l'établissement et on sortirait de
l'absurde oui il me semble et je pense
qu'on va y arriver
je pense avant dimanche à gauche enfin
j'en sais rien mais après ça s'est dit
ouvert le 15 décembre et politiquement
la prudence exigerait de ne pas le
retrouver dans des situations qui seront
ridicules avec des gens devant une
église qui peuvent pas y rentrer et
peut-être la police qui viendra vérifier
combien de personnes et les compter je
pense qu'il ya quand même d'autres
problèmes aujourd'hui et pour le pouvoir
en place et pour la police est pour
beaucoup de choses que de faire la
surveillance des messes le dimanche
matin quoi trouvez vous que le maintien
de la limite de 30 personnes par église
est une humiliation c'est la question
qu'on vous posez sur twitter vous êtes
53 4% estimé que non ce n'est pas une
humiliation notre émission de touche à
sa fin merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
merci d'avoir commenté ou posez vos
questions et merci à nos invités pour
leur point de vue
à très vite sur figaro live
[Musique]